hello everybody and welcome to the
British Council study UK event applying
to study in the UK my name is George
Wilson and I lead on higher education
for our teaching centers in France with
me today is nish ma and Padma and
they'll be helping me out with the
questions as they come in tonight
thank you say great thank you very much
so thank you for coming and let's get
stuck in
so next slide please
so the first part of our presentation
today will be why study in the UK now
there are many many different reasons
why students from around the world come
to the UK to study and many many do
there are four hundred eighty five
thousand six hundred students in the UK
who have come from different countries
all over the world and significantly
around 143 thousand of those students
are EU students now they come to the UK
because it provides particularly
multicultural diverse environment in
which people feel comfortable which is
something that is non-negligible it's
also important because we have
world-renowned for the quality of the
higher education that we offer there are
many different universities in the UK
but six of them are in the top 50
ranking of The Times Higher Education
supplement ranking and three are in the
top ten so you've got obviously
University of Oxford the University of
Cambridge and all of those two
universities that I mentioned are
renowned for different areas of study so
the quality is however not taken for
granted with the reason the UK is
respected and recognized around the
world is because there are strict
academic criteria that the government
enforces and polices we have to high
high levels of student satisfaction as
well that stem from that some studies
for them as the high is 90% which is
pretty impressive perhaps from the most
employment at Porton elements when
choosing where to study though is
employability will you be able to get a
job with your degree
once you've finished so employability in
the UK what the UK system prepares
people for the job market in a
particularly effective way in fact UK
graduates are some of the most
employable in the world according to Lee
the latest research
okay so there's some of the reasons that
study in the UK but there are more can I
have been exciting so studying in a UK
University and I'm saying University
because our higher education system
doesn't have this grande ecole
University distinction so to have study
in a higher education institution or
most normally a university um is to
study in a particular way you're given a
huge amount of freedom and you're given
a huge amount of independence so that
obviously means that for many people
it's the first time that then living and
studying away from home and with the
universities designed to provide a very
social experience for students living
and studying in new areas of the country
there are societies and sports clubs
that are run by the universities and
those societies can can be mind-blowing
in their diversity from tea-drinking
groups to might think my favorite is the
twenty-minute Society when you have 20
minutes to try and get away from where
you are and without being caught
so I mean there are all kinds of
different events going on in a very rich
social tapestry housing most
universities will guarantee housing and
accommodation for the first year of
study and there are a range of housing
options available often it will consist
of halls of residence so that's where
you all live in one building a bit like
Harry Potter and you eat often in one
place at that time you often have self
catering options where you can cook for
yourself and you also have houses which
are independent but are vetted or
controlled by the university so that you
can find and
in a private rental agreement with some
assurances in the second and third year
of your studies and/or the fourth
depending on how long your degree lasts
people tend to live in that kind of
private house
however some universities allow you to
come back into halls of residence for
your final year perhaps most importantly
however the UK is renowned for its style
teaching it's a very different approach
to the French system which is very
intensive in the number of hours
students have in the classroom in the UK
you have many fewer after your contact
hours so often for example I think in my
last year of university I had about four
hours a week but nonetheless I was very
very very very busy I spent all my time
in the library and that's the kind of
flipped approach that the universities
tend to adopt you put a lot of time and
effort into independent study that
encourages you to ask critical questions
debate ideas and think in a critical
manner another element of the UK
teaching style is the choice which
underlies most degrees when you take a
degree
you're usually choosing from a kind of
menu of modules to make up your degree
there will be some core modules there
with some optional modules you can also
often take what are called electives so
imagine you're studying history you
might choose to take a hundred credits
in history got 20 credits in
astrophysics or textiles or criminology
so those credits those elective modules
can be chosen from pretty much any
university department and gives you a
bit of variety in what you're studying
there are also joint honours degrees
which what I did where you choose the 32
subjects so I studied French and English
literature and at the end you get a da1
degree but divided between subjects you
can also finally do major major minor
combinations where you have more history
and less German for example another
characteristic of the system is the
tutor support there's a large degree of
contact between the teachers and the
students you'll have a personal tutor
will be there to look after your
well-being and check that you're okay
you also have academic tutors who are
there to support you in your studies now
there are usually a wide range of
assessment in the UK University
there could be take-home exams it could
be coursework
it could be essays it could be exams in
a big room again like Harry Potter so
that's just to give you an overall
experience of what life in the UK is
like when you're studying at high in a
higher education institution next slide
please
as I said before there are over a
hundred thousand foreign students living
in the UK these figures here show you
that in fact France has the highest
number of applicants for UK university
places of any country in the EU and by
quite a lot as well it's really quite a
long way behind so those figures are
from 2019 and I imagine you're asking
yourself will it change in the coming
years we'll come to that in a moment
next slide please
now what you might think there are lots
of French people coming to the UK why
would I get a place well the
demographics are on your side there are
not as many 18 year olds 19 year olds as
there used to be and therefore there are
fewer applications and there's less
competition universities really really
want students they're competing to get
students and therefore they're making
lots of generous offers to help help you
in the process of integrating a British
university next slide please
now that said obviously the situation is
more complicated this year I'm studying
him for a master's at the moment in
London and I go backwards and forwards
from France to London from Paris to
London each week or I did until The Cove
in nineteen at pandemic hips right now
it's very difficult to be studying
anywhere because of the social
distancing rules however a recent survey
and I say recent but it came out three
days ago
a recent survey shows that 97% of
British universities will provide
in-person teaching from September 2020
you may have heard that Cambridge is
planning not to they're planning not to
offer the big lectures the comedy school
but they aren't still intending as far
as we know to be offering face-to-face
situation for example in smaller groups
the universities are planning to make
different social distancing measures
obligatory so is to ensure that they can
be flexible and that you can still
partake of the university experience
with social event sporting events like
everyone they've had to adapt but
they're ready that said obviously you
have to take into account that right now
there's a - we quarantine for anyone
arriving in the UK I had a - recurring
team for anyone coming back to France
from the UK how long that will last
nobody knows but hopefully it will be
short-lived next slide please
now you might be wondering about the
money the money is quite an important
issue
at the moment the current fees the very
description are the same if you are in
France
sorry if you are from England or if
you're from France that is to say that
you would pay the same as I would so
that that's true for anyone who begins
their degree before the 1st of January
2021 so if you've been offered a place
now's a good time to be going
you pay the home fees remember the
United Kingdom has four constituent
countries England Scotland Wales and
Northern Ireland the fees are different
in each country of the United Kingdom
they're most expensive in England and in
Wales in Scotland there are no fees it's
free in Northern Ireland they're
considerably less in Wales it's worth
pointing out that you can apply for a
grant which dramatically reduces your
fees so it's a lot cheaper in fact than
it appears on this slide next slightly
so in addition to the very good
financial support or good fee
arrangements that you can benefit from
at the moment you are also eligible for
current financial support measures if
you begin your degree before the 1st of
January 2021 in that case you can apply
for a student loan like a British person
that student loan is a funny kind of
loan you don't reimburse unless you
begin earning a certain amount of money
so let's say for example the limit is
twenty thousand I'm not sure part of my
head let's say it's twenty thousand so
if one month one year I don't earn
twenty thousand pounds I don't have to
reimbursed it I can just wait and when I
start earning 24 hours and again then I
can reimburse it so it's a very
different type of loan there is interest
but it's quite low
next slide please
now unfortunately this is all changing
so everything I told you is true if
you're beginning your degree in
September 2020 but if you're beginning
your studies after the 31st of December
2020 in 2021 in England you will need to
pay international student fees now these
are quite a bit more they vary according
to the subject and the university but
they can range from eleven thousand to
thirty thousand pounds per year now when
we say that it's that's true of England
it's not necessarily true of Scotland
Wales and Northern Ireland this so this
information was released yesterday so we
haven't yet got any confirmation of what
will be the fee arrangements for the
other countries of the UK
you also will no longer be eligible for
the student loan but the universities do
offer scholarships and bursaries and you
should look at the universities
individual websites to find out more
about those and at our study UK pages
which give information about other
bursaries as I say the plans for the
other areas of the UK are not yet
announced but for England this is what
we know to be the case next slide please
visas so if your beginning before the
1st of January 2021
there is no visa required the students
must however when they arrive in the UK
apply for the EU settled settlement
scheme this is really simple and free
and online and it will give you the
right to remain in the UK you'll be able
to you'll be given either full settled
status or most probably pre settled
status and that means that you can stay
for the duration of your studies and
you'll also be able to stay for longer
if you apply for settled status in the
future which requires a certain number
of years of residency ok next slide
unfortunately exchanging has announced
yesterday the visa details for
international students beginning their
studies in 2021 have not yet been
confirmed they will be confirmed in the
autumn and you can follow the study UK
website in order to have the Loden most
up-to-date information however what has
been announced is a new scheme for
students that will come into effect in
summer 2021 called the graduate track
this will allow anyone who's graduated
from the UK University to stay and work
for up to two years after their studies
so that's good news next page please as
I've been saying all along the latest
information is all available on our
study UK webpage and it changes quite
often at the moment so it's really worth
looking at it you can find information
about loans and fees information about
moving to the UK budgeting about all
sorts of areas of what it's like to
study there so I strongly recommend it
to you next page
so as I've said before the UK really is
one of the world's premium destinations
for higher education the quality is
second to none yes the prices will be
more expensive in the future but when
you compare it to an American education
for example is still very cheap so I'd
strongly encourage you still to go ahead
and apply for a place at a university in
the UK now let's assume that I've won
you over and you would like to apply how
do you do it all the applications to the
UK higher education institutions go via
a charity organisation called you Cass
you see a s and you can see the link
here to their webpage you Cass guide
students through all stages of the
application procedure and it's a very
professional organisation you can ring
them up and ask any questions you might
have
next slide please
so how do you go about this process the
first stage of the process is to
research now whenever there are studies
of regrets by students they regret is
always not to have researched enough I
cannot stress how important it is to do
look at the UK's search tool it helps
you on the website find universities
that will offer a course that suits you
there are thousands of courses in the UK
and so it's really good idea to browse
and through this search engine and just
see what's out there for example and
that you could what - my friends study
wanting criminology and textiles I did
English and French wanted history in
business as I said before there are all
kinds of combinations joint honor
degrees so it's really worth looking in
them all there are also open days and
virtual-open days which perhaps a more
pertinent right now they allow you to go
and meet students to talk to students to
get an experienced what the campus is
like and what life is like living there
now that's important because you can't
necessarily get all the information from
a video for example remember if you do
use the virtual tours they've been
designed by the marketing departments
they've been designed to seduce you and
win you over however if you can't go to
the physical open day there are also
subtle in France often organized by late
regional and universities prevent
present their courses and we usually
have a wide range of universities
represented there they're also student
videos and blogs which are all on the UK
s website as well as the University of
the individual websites next one please
the British Council also organizes 30 UK
events last year we ran talks like this
we had a talk by an Oxford Cambridge a
Cambridge Don who told us about what
it's like to live there and study there
we also had an alumni event and we'll
have another in the next few months
which is a wonderful opportunity to talk
to people from France who studied in the
UK and ask them all the questions you
might have the you can very simply find
out about that on our web page what's
going on minimal in the French version
the web address is here and we'll send
you the PowerPoint at the end next one
Queen
so as I said before there are more than
370 universities in the UK and as you
can see from this the vast majority are
in England and therefore now are the
ones you'll have to pay a little extra
for for sure there's one in Europe can
anyone well you can't ask me but it
shares the building with the British
Council in Paris and it's the University
of London okay next slide please
now I said before used to search and do
lots of research well this is the page
that will let you do that you can see on
this page that the search engine
literally covers every course available
in the UK next slide please
so our top tips for research are to make
careful choices you're going to choose
five universities so with those five
universities you need to be thinking
about different things enjoyment what my
top tip for people studying with me is
always to choose something that really
excites you you're going to spend years
of your life studying it and then you're
going to hopefully work in something
related to it so you really kind of have
to follow your passion as much as you
can your career path though is important
think about what you're going to do
afterwards importantly in the UK if you
stay in the UK there's not the same
expectation that you'll have done so at
one particular path of study to adieu
one particular career so after my
English in French degree I could have
been a journalist or I could have been a
writer rather than the teacher that had
been an interpreter translator all in
the same rave realm
basically but then I could also have
worked in business I could have gone and
worked for a company like Accenture or
IBM and so what you're learning in the
UK degree is not necessarily the subject
knowledge you're learning the
transferable skills that are so valued
by employers across the world think
about the location of where you want to
study think about do you want to be on a
campus University you want to be on
inner city or do you want to do you want
to have everything in one place you want
to be in the countryside you want to be
in the middle of London think carefully
and make choices that reflect your own
preferences for where you'd like to live
think about access as well how often
you'll be coming back or won't be think
about what kind of style of study suits
you best do you work well of
Independence do you need some more
support
then choose your degrees accordingly
think about the extracurricular
activities many universities are famous
for their debating Club or for their
sports teams and obviously think about
the finances think about how you're
going to fund it what scholarships are
available in different universities next
one please
you might want to look at the rankings
the rankings are organizations that
produce a ranking or enlist in order of
from best to worst of the universities
in a country or internationally I've
given you a few examples here the first
one to three are particularly famous
ones that you'd probably want to look at
look not only by universities but also
by subject in English for example could
be better ranked in Leeds than it is in
Cambridge
so we're bearing that in mind
The Guardian people on planet one is a
really interesting one it looks at the
impact of the university on the
environment and sustainability it's
really interesting to see what kind of
university you want to be a part of is
it really taking care of the planet and
the teaching excellence framework is a
new initiative from the government that
ranks universities by gold silver and
bronze now that's a tricky one because
the system isn't necessarily working to
the best of its ability yet so look at
it but you'll find some surprising
results so you take them with a pinch of
salt be double check them in other
rankings next slide please
we talked about open days and virtual
tours with the animation I believe you
can see where to find this do we have
the next slide thing
so it was the applied to universities
for open dates so once you've decided to
apply a few facts the application is
entirely online
there are maximum five choices there are
some restrictions for example you can't
apply to Cambridge and Oxford there's a
simple one B which i think is about 26
pounds another check for 24 pounds sorry
if you want to make between 2 and 5
choices and if you only make one it's 18
pounds so it's very cheap you if you
meet the deadline of the 15th of January
all the 15th of October for some courses
you are guaranteed equal consideration
that is to say that they will read your
application and they would judge it on
its merits if you go after the deadline
they'll still read it probably but
they're not gonna guarantee they'll
treat you the same way as people who
were on time we'll come back to that
they're also guaranteeing you whatever
invisibility that is to say that if you
apply to Cambridge and Durham Durham
won't know that you've applied to
Cambridge and Cambridge won't know that
you've applied to Durham which can be
very harmful ok next slide so how do you
go about completing it first of all you
need to go through the six sections that
are on the application website the first
one's personal details now and a word
about that there's one box a
particularly problematic one box says
have you got a criminal record that
means have you been to prison and we
committed a crime thousand thousands and
thousands of people tick the box by
accident don't it's a very very bad
first impression to give a university
make sure your name is correct as well
lots of mistakes for that
choices as I said you're gonna make five
choices up to five choices and it's a
good idea to really think about what
you're looking for in your choices are
you looking for the same subject in five
different places or slightly different
subjects do they require the same grades
too some require a lesser grade
could they be a backup option insurance
choice things to consider
then education education is all the
grades that you've already officially
received that is to say if you took a
module in your French literature back
then you should include that when you
get the official result so it's things
you've done in premier or the first half
of tearing down employment employment is
only paid employment so for example if I
applied to be to do a degree now I've
got years of paid employment you
probably don't have years of paid
employment and that's fine then you've
got your personal statement which we'll
come back to in a moment and your
referee details now the referee details
are very very important so you're going
to choose somebody to write a reference
for you in English that gives a global
impression of your academic ability so
when you chosen that person you're going
to enter their details check with them
and then enter their details and they
will receive an email asking them to
upload their references to the website
the referee adds the reference and then
your application can be completed that
is to say that if the deadline is 15 for
January and you've finished your
application but you haven't got the
reference the reference from the referee
your application will not be complete
it's really important therefore to plan
ahead think who will I ask it could be
that you choose to ask your principal
teacher it could she be that you choose
to ask your English teacher
it doesn't really matter because that
person can go and ask and investigate in
all the different subjects okay lots of
people can write it but one person is
responsible for it it's then sent to you
Cass and then on to the University and
colleges okay next slide
now when do you do all this you start
well applications open on the 6th of
September then on the 15th October they
close but only for Oxford or Cambridge
and most courses in medicine dentistry
veterinary medicine or science the rest
of you you have until the 15th of
January 6 o'clock UK time so 7 o'clock
here in France for the majority of
undergraduate courses and so however if
I'm applying to Oxford and I've applied
to four other universities I still have
to put in my application for all of
those universities the one application
before the 15th of October so then you
can continue out there and submitting an
application until the 30th of June so
it's not too late next year not yet so
that means that after the 15th of
January you're not guaranteed that'll
read it but they probably will lots of
universities continue trying to fill
places right up to the 30 regime after
the 30 regime there are still options to
apply in a less classic way for a place
in September 2020 we'll come back to
that okay
next slide please
okay so the big everyone wants to ask
about is the personal statement this
really is the one part of your
application where you get to control the
narrative where you get to sell yourself
so you get it you need to put a lot of
time a lot of effort into your personal
statement now the personal statement is
the same for all of your University
choices that means that if I'm applying
to politics in one university and German
in another I somehow need to knit those
together they need to come together into
one unified statement and it can't
really begin with I'm applying to study
German because so you need to be very
skillful in the way you write this most
people apply for very similar courses in
different universities so it's not too
much of a problem there's a maximum of
four thousand characters or forty-seven
lines and a minimum of one thousand
characters you really need to use up
those four thousand characters however
do you be careful because the word count
on all the character counts on Microsoft
Word is not the same as the you cast one
so make sure you check that it's all
there when you upload it there's no
spelling or grammar check on you counts
and therefore you need to check it
before very very very carefully you can
write as one big paragraph because when
it comes out it will be one unit that
said we they're looking to see that you
can construct a good piece of writing
and good pieces of writing are generally
structured in paragraphs even if they
then get conflated in the system you
might want to ask for help now you can
ask for help but only really helpful
generating ideas help or checking the
grammar checking the spelling
if I say that because I've heard from so
many admissions tutors over the years
who told me that they know just like
that
if a coach wrote your personal statement
or helped too much they can see from the
level of English the level of vocabulary
they can just tell remember these people
spend their entire lives reading these
this is what they do all year right
suddenly for a big part of the year they
read thousands and they know if you
didn't do it yourself next slide please
so what are they looking for these
famous tuition tutors they're looking
for you to show them independent study
skills self-awareness motivation and
commitment an understanding of your
course that is to say you what you've
read for example about the course and
what you think about what you've read
remember critical thinking good numeracy
and literacy so they want to check that
your spelling is okay for example they
want you to show that you've got you've
done some research not only into the
universities but also it's a subject
they're testing your ability to write an
essay a short essay but an essay
nonetheless they're looking for
enthusiasm they want to proof that you
can manage your time that you've been up
against deadlines and perhaps most
importantly they want to see that you're
somebody who reflect will think
carefully and make informed decisions
next slide please
do you feel free to write questions in
the chat box and we'll come to them
later on at the end so top tips these
come from you cast itself a strong
opening paragraph be careful about the
strong opening paragraph I have always
wanted to be a dancer it's not true you
didn't you weren't born wanting to be a
dancer it's a cliche they don't want
cliches they want something that will
really grab their attention and say okay
we should take this person show that
you've researched courses your personal
statement should be about 80% academic
talking about subject talking about what
you hope to do what you've studied where
where what experiences you've had
dealing with essays and projects and
research and about 20% extra curricula
so clubs you've been a member of sports
you do Awards you won and so on be
honest as I say they know they're just
they've got a sixth sense for it they
know draft redraft and proofread it get
someone else to proofread it a good tip
is to give the personal statement to
somebody who knows you really well and
then ask them is this me have I gone too
far do I look like sound or do I sound
like someone else
and remember there's no perfect
statement so don't for a second think
you should be online looking for example
personal statements first of all them no
and secondly it's it doesn't need to be
a certain way it needs to be right for
you okay next slide
we've talked about this already actually
just one point I would like to draw your
attention to you that I didn't mention
is that within your reference that your
referee provides you they need to give a
predicted grade of the baccalaureate for
the overall back not for one subject so
they need to say for example I'll talk
to all his teachers ask what he's got
and the average
I'll take now it's this grade that will
be used by the universities to determine
if they ought for you a place they will
offer you a provisional place and then
when you're back when your score is
confirmed by the baccalaureate then
you'll be able to accept it so it's
really really important that they do
this it's kind of non-negotiable it's
also a chance in the reference for any
problems to be explained for example if
your college or sorry your leasing is
known to mark particularly hardly hard
in its coursework then that's a chance
to read them to say it it needs to be in
English it needs to be academic as well
okay thank you
next slide sometimes when you apply you
all have put in your application you
think oh I can relax and then they'll
write to you and say please come for an
interview or you need to do the one of
these exams and these ik entrance exams
can be organized in parents and they're
usually for medicine law yeah there are
two main ones reading next I agree
you're at some point you will probably
need to prove your English level as well
now that might be when you apply or it
might be that when you get given an
offer they will say you need 13 on the
baccalaureate and level 8 in IELTS for
example so it's you might want to start
thinking about that now or you might
want to wait until you put in your
application in any case to check what
they require to check whether they'll
accept one of your existing
qualifications and to check when they
need the grade you should contact the
individual university admissions
department they're very easy to get hold
of their email and phone numbers are
just on the websites now the most common
thing they'll ask you for is an IELTS
exam
this is anecdote test this is a test run
by the British Council and it gives and
it's the most popular in the UK and
probably in the world and it's valid for
two years and it gives you a score
now the score runs from one to nine
it's not saying you passed so you've
failed it's like a photograph it's like
a photograph of your English level it's
saying in reading your level seven that
means it doesn't mean you good or bad it
just means your level seven in writing
your little aims for example in
listening your level seven point five
and speaking level six then you get an
average of those grades now the
university will decide what they
consider to be an appropriate level
they'll usually ask for a certain level
overall and a certain certain level in
your writing well as I said it's valid
for two years and it needs to be valid
usually when you arrive at the
University
you can easily take the test it you just
have to go onto our website and a
British Council and you book a test
place which is usually every Saturday in
Paris if you need some extra support we
have IELTS support classes which lasts a
week and which give you an opportunity
to get the exam technique organized it's
important to do some practice in it
advance for the IELTS test it's yes it's
taking a photograph of your English
level but it's also you need to know
some exam technique you need to know
what to do in the different sections so
you need to research practice etc in
advance and next one please
so you can find lots of advice about
your application on the British Council
webpage new bloggers LeBlanc has all
kinds of tips and articles about how to
clients in the UK now just one last
thing about your English level you may
not need to do the IELTS they might
consider that your baccalaureate is
enough they might consider that your
IGCC is enough or something like that so
when you contact the university tell
them what you've got put it in the
education section of your of your
application and let them decide okay
next slide please
so you've sent your application in and
you can follow it through the
application process using this part of
the UK's website could track you means
you can look at whether your
applications have been sent in okay and
then you can see the choices you've made
and all of your personal info now when
you've sent in your application the
universities are going to start making
offers these offers will appear in track
they'll tell you also by what date you
need to have made a decision and decide
on which universities you want to accept
next slide please
you can see what it looks like here
okay next slide
so the universities will reply and they
will tell you one of three things first
of all you are unsuccessful or you are
um you were very successful and they'll
take you whatever happens then an
unconditional offer or most commonly a
conditional offer which means we would
love you to come and study with us if
you get 13 14 on baccalaureate 15 in
English or for example or 6 on the IELTS
7 on the IELTS and that offer is then
conditional on you achieving those
grades once you've made once you've
received all of your decisions you
choose up to two offers one is the firm
choice it's the one you're going to
accept the other is an insurance choice
if you didn't get the grades for your
firm choice you would accept you would
be accepted automatically by your second
choice as long as you got the grades
they require all the other offers are
declined automatically as soon as you
click on your final options on track as
I said track will show the date you need
to apply you need to reply back next
option next slide please
now let's say that you done the classic
journey through you casts in the classic
journey of you cats you have other
options that are available you have as
once if the classic journey wasn't the
one that worked out for you didn't get
any offers for example there are other
options available to you
extra means that you've used all five
choices and no one has chosen you or
you've decided you don't want to go to
any of those five choices in that case
you can add an extra choice of
consideration one at a time
via track clearing is a different option
it means that after the 30 of June if
you haven't got any offers or you've
declined all your offers you can go onto
the website and search for places which
are free which haven't been fulfilled
from the 5th of July and you can add one
choice via
track finally you have the option of
adjustment that means that if you got a
better score than you expected to get
there's an option there to look for an
even better University and so that's
something to consider but this is quite
detailed and you don't need to worry
about it now however if you wanted to
apply for September 2020 and you didn't
make the 30th of June deadline you could
use clearing to try and get a place ok
next slide
so there's
ways which parents can help make sure
that you use the set parents Guardian
section of the UK s website there are
information tools on there offered to go
to open days be sensitive when you book
holidays make sure that they the student
reads everything that sent to them for
us it will all go wrong and help them
support them talk to them okay next
slide please
as I said before you have a phone number
where you can ring up you cats and ask
them any questions you have okay next
slide please
and of course the British Council is
here to help you as well
we run courses for adults and young
learners and you can find all the
details just here these courses prepare
students for university study in English
now that might be in the UK it might be
in America or it might be in France or
Germany more and more universities
across the world are offering lessons in
English meaning they're not teaching
English they're teaching German or sorry
let's teach in chemistry for example but
they're using English to communicate in
the classroom in the essays and the
exams see ah school in Paris on Tyler I
could name hundreds of higher education
institutions in France that are doing
the same thing to some extent so our
courses will prepare you by giving you
an insight into the application
procedures of different countries giving
you support with your personal statement
or essays by giving you some some
critical thinking skills through our
study of literature which will help you
be ready for the kind of study you'll be
doing in UK and by simulating the
university preparation the university
cycle of lecture seminar essay
presentation etc we give you guidance in
academic skills whether it be writing
essays language for universities through
to different grammar techniques to
really succeed in your essays listening
to lectures participating in seminars
and so on we also give you guidance on
the IELTS test so these classes run from
September to June and they're three
hours a week normally on a wednesday
afternoon or evening I should say from
five till eight at the moment and
they're in just near our Centre in and
near and the league
so we also one run one week courses for
adults in which we do a kind of
condensed more focused version of what
we've just discussed that's usually for
people going to postgraduate study but
it could also be for Erasmus or it could
be for undergraduate study next slide
please
there is some useful websites you'll see
here that provide information as I say
study UK is your big focus point or find
the information and I think that brings
us to the end so next slide
so I'm gonna hand over to measurement
ask her a therapy opinion are there any
questions people would like answered
thanks so much
George yes so we do have a couple of
questions so I think the first one is do
you know how people can get volunteer
experience at hospitals this particular
student wants to study medicine in the
UK do you have any addresses or any
ideas as to how this person kids get
experience basically in the UK that's a
really good question obviously at the
moment it's a bit tricky to go into a
schools at all I'm not sure we have any
addresses that could help you with that
in particular but I guess writing to
local health authorities to universities
or perhaps just smaller clinics like
doctors surgeries would be a good start
though your personal statement I'm just
gonna put you back on the main screen
okay so another question do you know if
it's possible to take the U cat exam for
medicine in France and if yes where is
it possible to do that I'm not sure off
the top of my head but you can find most
of the exams in France most UK entrance
exams are run in Paris somewhere so good
Google search I think would be your best
bet okay
and this is another question which I
guess is just in light of yesterday but
what kind of advice would you give to
students who are just worried about
recent developments in terms of
university fees etc so I think in terms
of the Reiser situation first of all the
recent be too problematic we hope I
don't think that's too much of a
deciding factor in terms of fees
obviously you have to have the money now
to be able to do your university
studying in England and I hope well who
knows
but maybe in the rest of the UK as well
I would say really really up-to-date
using the study UK websites on the
latest developments make sure that you
know exactly what's going on there are
bursaries out there there are
scholarships out there universities are
desperate to keep you to keep people
from the EU so they'll be doing
everything they can to try and attract
you to the UK so when you choose your
universities contact them and see what
they can offer what possibilities are
out there for you
curry and I think that's everything so
everything we have great well thank you
very much for your patience I know
there's a lot of information everyone
and we'll send you the slide so you can
get your head around it
Thank You knishmas thanks George thank
you goodbye